these are some of the scenes
providing the backdrop to the
president's visit to california
raging wildfires that have burned
millions of acres
wiped out whole communities and left
dozens dead
scientists say blazes like these are
being made worse
by climate change
but donald trump spoke of other concerns
after landing in california to meet with
top officials
and we have to do a lot about forest
management obviously forest management
in california is very important
california governor gavin newsom said
those concerns were justified
but he and other officials went on to
press trump
on climate change not done justice on
our forest management
the science is in and observed evidence
is self-evident that climate change is
real
and that is exacerbating this if we
ignore that science and sort of put our
head in the sand and think it's all
about vegetation management
we're not going to succeed together
protecting californians okay
it'll start getting cooler you just
watch
i wish science agreed with you hey well
i don't think science knows actually and
earlier that day harsh words from
trump's democratic presidential rival
joe biden
if you give a climate arsonist four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised if we have
more america blaze
if you give a climate denier four more
years in the white house why would
anyone be surprised
when more of america is under water
but trump has his supporters even in
deeply democratic california
i was displaced by the tubbs fire
i woke up with my city in flames
and the democrats have not done their
due diligence
policy wise and so if there is a
component of global warming
it is a very very small component
because the democrats
are failing california meanwhile
firefighters on the front lines face
challenging conditions with shifting
winds and drier weather
sparking several new blazes
let's get more now with dw's i mean sf
joining us from the capitol building
in sacramento california good day to you
amiens
these fires are absolutely catastrophic
the images certainly are
are very disturbing and and they've also
become highly
politicized how are they playing a role
in president trump's campaign strategy
considering he only spent
just a few hours in california
that's right it was a quick stop and it
was unplanned that was not part of his
trip out west part of his campaign trail
if you will
but he came in anyway and it seems to
show
that trump is conscious that with these
fires
unprecedented fires making headlines
nationally and internationally he had
to finally say something he's been quite
silent about that for a couple of weeks
he wants to perhaps look like he has the
situation
under control now in the meeting as you
can see
uh he deflected criticism that this was
his fault
and uh said that it had more to do with
forest management
in california oh uh amien
what's been the reaction from some of
the voters uh where you are
to the president's visit
well this is a largely democratic state
which is one of the reasons
why he hadn't planned on coming here
he's not really worried about the votes
here
he thinks he'll lose the state anyway he
lost to hillary clinton
by 4 million votes in the last elections
so this wasn't a part of his planned
trip because the voters here are already
turned against him
just two years ago he said that
californians need to rake their forest
more
and totally denied that climate change
had anything to do with this this
doesn't sit well with the people here
especially since the federal government
owns more than half
of the forest in california and the
state only owns three percent
so it doesn't sit well with those voters
there were a lot of trump supporters at
the airport
this morning however to see air force
one
land to give their their support
for their presidential candidates so
there is a bit of a mix here but then
again there was
protests there as well and they clashed
with trump supporters
yeah we heard that some of those
anti-trump protesters actually
ended up in hospital during the
president's visit can you tell us more
about that
it was a scene that's becoming much more
common
in the united states where protesters
protesting trump black lives matter
protesters
lining the streets blocking traffic are
hit by
cars now this happened in two separate
separate instances
uh here in sacramento where protesters
were attempting to block the streets
and cars just ran into them or
sideswiped them
and that sent two people to the hospital
there was another instance of a
protester climbing up on a police
vehicle
and being dragged away by that vehicle
okay now
the president's visit comes as
california struggles with the pandemic
with
the effects of the lockdown what kind of
economic
impact are these fires having
some estimates brian have put that
figure at 150
billion dollars in costs to
the the west coast because of these
unprecedented wildfires
that's a big number but to put that into
human figures this means
thousands of homes thousands of
businesses
burnt to the ground this means thousands
of people homeless
hotels are almost fully booked in this
area it's hard to find a hotel room
because so many families have been
displaced by these fires there was
actually
a collection of cans of canned food at
some hotels
in around here this morning for the
people here so
i don't want to exaggerate but i have to
say it is bleak here especially with the
pandemic and california still being in
partial lockdown
i mean that's it for us in sacramento
california thanks so very much for that
update